[Music]
the story of the finder found in ursula
k the greens tales from earth sea is in
part the story of the young man otter
turn medra different names that he goes
by
who is indeed a finder but it's also a
much larger story and a much more
important story about the
founding of the school of magic
and of the high arts at roke now roque
island is already a very magical place
the imminent grove is there the women of
the hand had already for at least
several hundred years established
a community of magic users that were
extending their their power
out secretly into the other aisles of
earth sea in its dark times but the
establishment of an actual school
and the decision to one turn away from
you know complete isolation
and back again outward to earth sea is a
very
important one and it is founded
in a concern for freedom they realize
that the only way that they can be
truly
free is to bring freedom to
others to prepare the way
for an earth sea that will not be such a
terrible place
so they
set this up as a school as ember says
where the wise might come to learn from
one another to study the pattern the
grove would shelter us and they talk all
winter about it all the wise women of
the island what was the true art of
magic where did it turn false how the
balance of things was kept or lost what
crafts were needful which useful which
dangerous why people had one gift but
not another whether you could learn an
art you had no native gift for
in such discussions we learn
they worked out name the names that have
ever been given to the masteries
finding weather working changing healing
summoning patterning naming and the
crafts of illusion and the knowledge of
the songs those are the arts of the
masters of rock even now though the
chanter took the finder's place when
finding came to be considered a merely
useful craft unworthy of a mage it was
in these discussions the school on rogue
began ursula k leguin tells us and she
is the one who would know right it's her
secondary world then she tells us
there are some who say the school had
its beginnings far differently and she
gives us some sort of misogynistic thing
that the wizards of the present day tell
themselves and she says well this is all
bunk there's a bit of truth to it here
and there but it's it's mainly made up
stuff and you know it's interesting that
that she's actually giving us
a insight into
the
fabrication of
origin stories and this is quite
important
because we're going to see that there
are tensions arising
even in the early days of rogue
first though we should talk about taren
who is medra and his finding finding is
his art right and so he's been finding
ore underneath the earth before he's
been you know finding other things now
he's going to find people and his first
finding mission
is taking crow
who very much loves books but doesn't
have any magical talent to try to find
the book of names and eventually they
you know they go to a lot of places find
various books here and there and then
eventually they
arrive on some some women of the hand
making the sign
and
then
they they find a book right a witch's
den
uh healers
and they wind up finding
not just the book of names but the very
first student
for a rock a young woman named dory who
will go back with them and in the
process crow
finds his
profession we read the school on rope
got its first student from across the
sea together with its first librarian
the book of names which is kept now on
the islet tower was the foundation of
the knowledge and method of naming which
is the foundation of the magic of rogue
the girl dory who as they said taught
her teachers became the mistress of all
healing arts and the science of herbals
and established that mastery in high
honor at oak as for crow
unable to part with the book of names
even for a month he sent for his own
books from oremy and settled down with
them and twill he allowed people of the
school to study them so long as they
showed them and him due respect so that
is the beginning of the outward journeys
and then we find out that there are
voyages
every year that turn is doing in his
ship hopeful seeking out students of
magic potential people for roke in late
spring he would go out
seeking and finding people for the
school children and young people mostly
who had a gift of magic sometimes grown
men and women most of the children were
poor though he took none against their
will their parents or masters seldom
knew the truth and he winds up becoming
a scary figure the child taker a dreaded
sorcerer who carried children to his
island in the icy north and suck their
blood right but at that time there were
many people of the hand who knew what
was afoot on rock
also young people are being sent to rock
men and women came to be taught
and to teach so we have both the finder
going out and finding students and we
have the hand sending people
inward and rock is now developing into
something and they don't quite know
exactly what form it's going to take but
there's two things that are really
centrally important one is building the
house the great house of roke the one
that we find out about in a wizard of
earth see right uh when he goes to rock
from from gantt um
the beginning of uh the third novel as
well the farthest shore when aaron goes
into the house and building the house is
much easier
than as they say
building the rule
um
we they have to settle the issue
of the rule
and um
ember says off you go and leave us to
settle this matter and uh taran says
i'll stay if you want and and she says i
do want you to stay but don't stay
you're a finder you have to go to find
it's only that agreeing on the way or
the rule juarez wants us to call it is
twice the work of building the house and
causes ten times the quarrels i wish i
could get away with from it and he says
why do we quarrel and there's going to
be a discussion of that later where
they'll say well different people have
different interpretations and they come
from different areas so culture plays a
role in the quarreling but warris it
also has some ideas of his own that go
against
you could say the ethos the
egalitarianism
of the women of the hand who've been
running rogue and she says gather 20 or
30 people of power in a room they'll
each seek to have your own way if you
put men who've always had their way
together with women who've had theirs
they'll resent each other then there are
some true and real divisions they must
be settled and he says is it waris
warris and several other men and they
are men and they make that
important beyond anything else
to them the old powers are abominable
and women's powers are suspect because
they suppose them connected with the old
powers as if those powers were to be
controlled or used by
any mortal soul but they put men where
we would put the world and so they hold
that a true wizard must be a man
that's one issue right there
and
celibate
they also want to have their own
room or their own wing of the house so
they can be pure and what we see here is
a kind of separatism that leads to
a domination you know
this is eventually going to lead to the
the male dominated rock that we
encounter in the other earth c novels
when it wasn't that way to
begin with
and uh
you know she says um
it's not my word it's worse's they want
the rule of rock to separate men from
women and they want men to make the
decisions for all here's the big problem
what compromise can we make with them
why did they come here if they don't
want to
work with us
and he says well we should send away the
men who won't and she says away
in anger to tell the lords of watt hood
or hovnor that which is on rogue are
brewing a storm so they're kind of stuck
with these guys and that will eventually
lead to them
dominating we also find that there is an
attack an attack from hovnor itself led
by the
wizard early the apprentice of gaelic
who has gotten losing's fleet at his
disposal
we find that they're unable to actually
make much headway against roke and
early flies to rock and tries to attack
it and what he finds out is that things
are far too
powerful
there for for him all the rumors of rock
said it was spell defended and charm
hidden if there were any spells about
that hill or bay he now saw opening they
were gossamer to him transparent
he lands as a dragon
and then suddenly stands in his own form
and then they ask him tell me your name
and he said teriel why did you come here
tyriel to destroy you
and and she says destroy us destroy this
hill these trees here maybe segue who
made them could unmake them maybe the
earth will destroy yourself
false king false dragon false man don't
come to rock noll until you know the
ground you stand on
and he sees there's many other people he
thinks that he's going to make a spell
but he he made no spell he had no magic
left in him it was gone run out of him
into this terrible hill into the
terrible ground under him he was no
longer a wizard only a man like the
others
powerless and that's the end of early
that's the end of the attack on rogue
and what do we find here well the rogue
has organized itself into a school
through goodwill also through conflict
and we find that there are not just
students but there are indeed
masters
as we mentioned dory becomes the master
herbal
ember becomes the master patterner we
have the others the summoner the changer
the namer
and
we have a master finder medra is
originally the master finder
when uh
his love ember dies he goes to the grove
and he leaves that behind and a new
finder arises in his place and we have a
vignette towards the very
end of the story itself that is going to
show us
his place
here we go
growing old ella hall that's that's
ember's true name wearied of the
passions and questions of the school and
was drawn more and more to the trees
where she went alone as far as the mind
can go medra walk there too but not so
far as she for he was lame
after she died he lived for a while in
the small house near the grove
one day in autumn he came back to the
school he went in by the garden door
which gives out on the path through the
fields to rock knoll it is a curious
thing about the great house there is no
portal or grand entryway at all you can
enter by the back door which though it
is made of horn and framed dragon's
tooth looks like nothing at all from the
outside
or you can come in by the garden door
but there is no front door he came in
through the halls and stone corridors to
the inmost place
hearing he was there the teachers of roe
came the men and women who were masters
of their craft medra had been the master
finder until he went to the grove a
young woman now taught the art as he had
taught it to her and here is a important
innovation
i've been thinking he said
there are eight of you
nine's a better number
count me as a master again if you will
what will you do master turn ask the
summoner a gray-haired mage from ilion
i'll keep the door said medra said being
lame i won't go far from it being old
i'll know what to say to those who come
being a finder i'll find out if they
belong here
that would spare us much trouble and
some danger said the young finder how
will you do at the summoner asked i'll
ask them their name he smiled and if
they tell me they can come in and when
they think they've learned everything
they can go out again if they can tell
me my name
so it was for the rest of his life medra
kept the doors of the great house on
rogue
the garden door that opened upon the
knoll was long called madras gate even
after much had changed in the house as
the centuries passed through it and
still the ninth master of rock is the
door keeper and so that is how the story
ends with the institution of roke now
established heading towards
unfortunately male domination and female
exclusion
but well founded in earthsea to take up
its mission as a force
of goodness of freedom
and of teaching and learning in this
world that ursula k leguin created
you